Speaker 1: Let's start today with inflation.
Now, I want to approach this from an economic
perspective, because I've been getting dozens
of emails from people wanting an explanation
about how inflation eventually goes away.
And I've touched on this a little bit,
but let's talk about it in more detail. Now, when
I say I don't want to make this a political story.
There are some political statements I have to make
because there is so much political misinformation
around inflation. There has been inflation, high
inflation all over the world. Some countries with
higher inflation than the United States. Some
countries with lower inflation than the United
States. There are many in the U.S. who want to
blame Joe Biden for inflation. I have found no
evidence that Joe Biden is to blame. And in
fact, the U.S. is not at the highest or at
the lowest level of inflation over the last year.
This is a global phenomenon related to a lot of
different things that we've talked about. And for
those pointing specifically to Joe Biden's COVID
relief package as the reason for the inflation,
remember that Donald Trump did two such packages
and they were bigger than Joe Biden. So if that's
why you blame Biden, you have to blame Trump
at least two times as much. And none of these
people are so like with the political stuff out
of the way. There's lots of confusion about like,
how does inflation eventually go away? And one of
the realities about inflation is that sustained
inflation will eventually reduce inflation. And
I'm going to explain to you how that works.
But when people talk about markets and cycles,
this is actually what we mean. One of the best
there are many examples of markets that don't work
or are kind of pie in the sky fantasy. They don't
relate to how the real world works when it comes
to inflation. Ultimately resolving inflation, it
actually does work this way. So to start this,
let's talk about what is a good level of
inflation or deflation or no price changes,
like what would we want? Well, a really high level
of inflation is bad because people very quickly
can't afford things. It's bad for the economy
because things get so expensive that others
don't buy anything. So it's bad for business.
It makes it so that people's wages no longer can
keep up with the cost of living. So really, high
inflation is bad and we're seeing high inflation,
at least by American historical standards right
now. It might seem like, well, then, is deflation
good? Because if prices go down, people can afford
stuff. No, deflation is also bad. And again, the
framework here is the framework is the traditional
understanding of how modern economies work.
You could say, David, sir, the entire framework is
crap. Put it in the trash and that's a different
discussion. But at least in the modern economic
framework. Deflation is bad because if you
expect things to get cheaper in the future, you
would wait to buy them. I mean, okay, things you
absolutely need, you're not going to say, well,
I won't eat for a month because food will be
cheaper in a month. No. Then you're dead. You need
food, but with a ton of different purchases if you
expect prices to be lower in the future because
we are in the middle of a deflationary situation,
you would say I'm going to wait to buy stuff.
And when you don't buy, businesses don't have
money coming in, meaning they have to lay off
workers. And now those workers don't have money
to buy things because they've been laid off. So
that's a deflationary spiral that's also bad.
So in traditional economics, the understanding
is you want a little bit of inflation,
a little bit of inflation is where economic
growth comes from. A little bit of inflation
is the reason why people would you're not going
to go hoarding supplies, but you would purchase
things. If I want to look at a car and the car
is affordable today, the car is ten grand and I
can afford ten grand if I expect the car will be
eight grand next year. I wait. I don't buy it.
If the if the car is already unaffordable, I
don't buy it. But if the car is ten grand today
and I expect it to be $10,500 in a year, that's a
pretty good reason to go and buy the car today. So
I'm now supporting the dealership. I'm supporting
the manufacturer. Okay. So that's the framework
for why we say a little bit of inflation is good.
Let's talk about then what happens when there is
inflation. Inflation initially creates more
inflation. People fear while prices are going up,
they might go even higher. I've got to go and
buy stuff now before I can no longer afford it.
That increases inflation even more and things
start to cost more for workers. So the workers
demand more wages and to cover the increased
wages, the employers start charging more for the
products and you have an inflationary cycle. This
only works in the short term because you can only
pre-purchase so much stuff. You can only get
ahead before prices go up so long. Eventually,
inflation is going to reduce the purchasing power
for people. People aren't going to be able to buy
as much. UFF A great example is like with a house,
if you've got a down payment saved up and you can
afford $1,000 a month mortgage at a 3% mortgage,
maybe your house that you can afford is 200 grand.
When mortgage rates go up, as we see inflation.
You can no longer afford a $200,000 house because
to keep your payment at 1000 bucks because of
the higher rate, now you can only afford $180,000
house. This then puts pressure on the home seller
to decrease the price. So eventually inflation,
which takes away purchasing power, starts to make
a downward pressure on prices. And that ultimately
is what reduces the inflation. Now, obviously
there's problems with doing nothing because in
the short and medium term, while this is going
on, people start to be unable to afford things
that they need. Poor people are hurt the most by
this inflationary cycle. So you've got to figure
out how do we deal with that? And there's a hole,
but that's beyond the scope of this segment. But
there's a whole bunch of things that governments
can do to say, well, let's let's figure out how to
support folks who can't afford certain necessities
during this period of time. High inflation can
hurt business innovation because it starts to get
more expensive to start a business. Someone might
say, I'm not going to start the business. Well,
it's a business that could have employed people.
It's a business that could have manufactured a
product or provided a service. So that's not good
for the economy either. And you've got to figure
out how to deal with that. None of this is to
pretend that anything is any worse or better than
it actually is. It's to gain an understanding of
how longer term inflation will reduce inflation.
In the meantime, we have to take very seriously
the effect that it has on people, the effect that
it has on the economy. But for people who say,
well, why can't Joe Biden just like sign something
and fix this issue in an economy the size of the
economy of the United States? No, the answer is
no. And the mechanism that will ultimately reduce
that inflation to some degree is inflation itself.
Let me know if that's clear or if it's not clear.